et on a vu ce document sera invité du
soir c'est stan wawrinka qui est avec
nous le joueur de tennis couverts
oh
stanislas
voilà quel bonheur et stanislas wawrinka
merci d'être là stanislas wawrinka alors
ya roland-garros qui débute lundi et
j'ai je mise tout sur vous j'ai voué
monfils hier et c'est risqué
voilà je vous le dis alors vous avez
gagné le premier tournoi du grand chelem
faut dire en tennis 6 à 4 très grands
tournois dans l'année
il ya donc l'open d'australie qui se
passe et laura bravo ya roland-garros
ensuite y'a wimbledon à londres et
ensuite il ya us open qui se passe aux
etats unis
et vous vous avez gagné l'open
d'australie donc le premier grand
tournoi c'était contre nadal en finale
on a des images regarder sans s'étendre
et donc du service de stam il monte à la
volée
et stanislas wawrinka qui gagne l'open
d'australie alala énorme face à nadal
qui était redevenu numéro un mondial et
de pluie
et depuis stanislas enchaîne les
victoires
non mais c'est vrai et où fait partie
des grands favoris de roland garros
thales que vous connaissez la télévision
française ou pas oui connaissez une
émission bien sûr connu alors est-ce que
vous lui par luis palau îles c'est quoi
son rôle dans l'émission jean luc
lemoine raconter des conneries et delà
c'est quoi son rôle c'est de la merde et
bien isabelle morini-bosc va s'arrêter
là je crois que c'est un peu risqué un
dernier jean michel maire
voilà c'est dangereux c'est sur les
femmes seulement tout le monde stan en
tout cas merci d'être là bourse et qui
c'est qui votre principal adversaire sur
roland garros et nadal encore il va être
dur à battre cette année encore là en
disant que nadal et djokovic sont les
favoris moi je suis un peu derrière
si vous avez gagné deux tournois sur
terre battue je n'ai rien inventé moi je
rajoute un monsieur roland garros à la
fois et c'est en train de se détacher
merci thierry moreau games qui n'arrête
pas de me faire des sites depuis tout à
l'heure il met la main sur le coeur je
croyais qu'ils voulaient que chantent la
marseillaise et pas compris stanislas
vous le savez ici il ya un rituel il ya
le mini ping pong savais que je n'ai
alors jamais perdu au mini ping pong
affronter bartoli elle est venue elle a
pris une tannée elle est repartie
c'est vrai ça frottait galles sont
entrepris l'année sont rentrés chez eux
r2 bon d'accord vous avec numéro trois
mondial vous jouez un petit peu au mini
pelles bon vous êtes un
jamais jamais non ce qu'on pensait qu'on
pouvait me battre oui bien sûr
des gens qui peuvent séjourner à
sarrians tillon je vous arrête de suite
je suis pas natale pas tes petits
copains nadal federer djokovic moi c'est
pas pareil il a amené la table
stanislas wawrinka a merci mon chéri
merci safran s'est adjugé le massacre je
fais exprès toujours pour mettre
l'adversaire
patricio pour la joue en cinq sets au
bas en cinq sets excuse moi tu sais tout
et stanislas piot sur le physique
normalement je sais ce que je suis
ces trois points répartis un point bas
du stade ils croient qu'ils vont me
battre à moi le champion tunisien
pakistano tu marques faut jouer des
heures comme ça mais tu joues à roland
garros on va toujours dit que mon verre
était mauvais fautive à battre voulait
pas continuer l'émission
à mon avis on va faire en deux points
sinon il était jusqu à demain ce que moi
je t'explique cela serait pas choquant à
l'afutt joseph je m'attend
m
continuer j'en fais j'en appelle à
johnny combat non non non attention jan
bucquoy il y encore trois points
favre il revient vite parce que les
règles en plein match si je suis
tunisien pas les règles un match c'est
pour que je gagne son poison gagnant 100
points ce matin à l'eysée partie du
deuxième pont bravant la honte devant
tous ses copains à roland garros contre
c'est comme ça dit que je perds contre
un accord de renoncer à vannes on voit
qu'ils ont fait pas gagner roland avait
passé et oui c'est vrai que j'ai gagné
ça va vite oui ça va dit la ministre
les gars ont pas d une grande table voit
la grande poste
dire que la bande am ça veut dire que tu
abandonnes sur la petite non moi je
viens il ya 2 0 a bien mal et c'est
parti à prôner la rade
et on y va à fait légaux alors la numéro
trois mondiale
voilà la grande table il parle mais moi
ça me dégoûte fin qui perçoit le
supporter n'a pas de nom il avait bien
un court de tennis
plus grands aussi à 3 078
cette dernière chance au tennis acheta
l'islam et ses produits jours merci les
chéris des abonnés ce stade ci auprès
patricia ils ont fait un commerçant la
rue merci d'assaut la rue du brun grand
tennis on est mieux la raquette
voilà voilà c'est parti c'est énorme
trois points très franchement pas
l'essai au poids légers le soleil c'est
drôle
allez c'est parti
roj c'est vraiment drôle 01/06 le ballon
plus forts d'inversion brinkley un lourd
passé il a compris
c'est pas terrible et les flics disant
rien il protège mais ouais c'est cool et
il a pris mon mal de matches balle de
match pour stanislas à attention j'ai
trouvé une nouvelle technique
je suis
et de tout donner
l'élection c'est la prière battu voilà
et la piscine pouvait jouer je voudrais
jouer avec boîte grinta et nous ne nous
sommes pas tous je me comporte comme ça
mal une manette gc sion